- So Colin Hanks was recently on the show.
And well, he said this.
- Someone came up to me and say,
"What's up fake Nick Jonas."
- [Kelly] Fake Nick Jonas
- And the reason why they said
that was because in Jumanji,
I play like the main kid that
gets sucked into the game.
- Yes
And in the game I was
played by Nick Jonas.
- But in real life when you come back
and you live your life.
- It's me.
- Yeah.
- So in reality, he's fake Colin Hanks,
but no one calls him that.
- That's rude.
(clapping)
- Now for the record,
I've never been called fake Colin Hanks.
- Okay. Oh, you've never been called that.
Oh, that's so interesting.
- Yeah, but I just hope
that you don't confuse us
because we've had a lot of history now.
- Totally. I didn't not at all.
Not at all.
Like I just, I, well, I mean, you.
- Hold on. This is the
real test amongst friends.
- Wait. No.
- What am I am I in your phone as?
- No, you were, I mean,
it's just Nick Jonas.
- Yeah.
- It's just Nick Jonas, there's
nothing, there's no like.
- Well, no.
- Well.
- Calling you now.
- No, it's totally.
- Well it, it might, it might.
- Okay.
- It might say fake Colin Hanks.
(clapping)
Look,
look.
- Okay.
- It was funny, it was funny.
- Yeah, that's really funny.
- And I'm like, no one calls you.
(laughing)
No one calls you fake Colin
Hanks. It's like my own.
- I won't be making my monthly
trip to your show next month.
- It's my only.
- Kidding.
- Look I'm the only one with
this really cool nickname.
- Yeah, yeah. No it's good.
- Because nobody would, yeah
like you said nobody does that,
but it is funny that he
gets called fake Nick Jonas.
- I love him and I loved playing
the version of him in the game.
- Fake Colin Hanks.
And I've only ever met him once.
- Oh really?
- And we have played each other
twice now in two Jumanji's.
- That's interesting.
- Yeah, so, and actually
I have spent more time
with his parents than him.
- His parents are fun.
- Very fun.